so the final speaker of our first
today will be
she's the cultural heritage program
manager for the United States Department
of State's Bureau of South and Central
Asian affairs she has worked of extended
periods of time in Afghanistan and she
would speak to us about what Christ
culture destruction and culture heritage
preservation in Afghanistan since 2001
hello good afternoon good morning
something delighted to be here honor to
be here today and thank you for
listening to this very brief overview of
some cultural destruction in Afghanistan
and I hope that in the midst of some of
the more devastating images from
Afghanistan and well we've seen a lot
and we'll see a lot today there will be
some images that also bring a bit of
hope that not all is lost I'm just going
to jump right into it and for those who
have visited Kabul and the National
Museum in Kabul this plaque may look
familiar to it's very simple yet elegant
statement that sits at the middle just
at the main entrance of the National
Museum of Afghanistan and it was erected
in 2002 when the staff of the National
Museum could return after the fall of
the Taliban and when the museum still
had only a partial roof and most of its
galleries had been destroyed through
rocket attacks mostly unintentional
rocket attacks i'm going to start
quickly with a map also just to orient
that I hope in the seven minutes that
I'll speak there will visit some in
Kabul we'll talk about that I want to
show some work in Ghazni and some
destruction there and if there's time at
the end I'd like to talk a little bit
about a very interesting site just south
of Kabul called mess I knock so these
images more or less speak for themselves
in terms of what the extent of damage
was to the National Museum of
Afghanistan which had been founded in
the 1920s and in its day was the finest
Archaeological Museum in all of Central
Asia its vast collections were all
systematically excavated material from
the territory of Afghanistan mostly by
French German British some American and
Afghan archeological expeditions
entirely destroyed because it had the
unfortunate location of being situated
between two fighting
in the Afghan Civil War during the
Afghan Civil War the museum was also
looted estimates were that seventy
percent of its collection we think
around seventy thousand objects looted
by Afghan mahajabeen and where those
objects remain where they went is a
question to be answered we do know some
you can find some of the objects with
Museum numbers for sale in markets in
Kabul difficult to recover those because
much of the looting that took place are
now were by individuals who now are
individuals of power in the Afghan
government just some images to the
numismatics collection entirely looted
catalogues burned but as an image of
something optimistic the museum was
reconstructed and is in the process of
being reconstructed by intrepid
international workers long before
frankly the United States became
involved in any restoration work at the
national museum or the Department of
State did these this with the good
results of other donors work and some
before and after shots of what the
specific galleries looked like upper
left same gallery now if you were to
visit today on the upper right lower
left and lower right
for the last four years the university
of chicago under support from the
department of state but has been doing a
cattle creating a catalog of the
collections of the national museum
because in the years of destruction and
then the last 14 or decade or so of
trying to sort of rehabilitate the
national museum there was no existing
catalog of what the actual holdings were
and while cataloging may seem somewhat
of a dull and you know not an entirely
sort of sexy project to do it however as
we know as museum professionals and
archaeologists it really does create the
core the backbone of any operational
museum so the team from the University
of Chicago has been working side by side
with the young staff of the National
Museum to create a bilingual what we
call dual lingual catalog between dari
the national language and English so
that the Afghan staff whose English
skills may not be quite fluent can enter
data about an object in dari and it is
immediately translated into English
through a very standardized catalog
system with vocabulary that's already
been put in so you know as a ceramic pot
can be described consistently with the
exact same vocabulary for example store
oh let me go back I also would like to
say that the condition of the National
Museum it's difficult to describe but it
will maybe be familiar to many of you
there's no climate control the the
plumbing leaks in the storerooms there's
vermin there's security as a padlock on
the door with some drowsy guys with
ak-47s it's not ideal and the storerooms
in particular were in very bad condition
and it's not stated as a criticism as
and that is just simply how it was and
in the aftermath of the Taliban and I
didn't even really get into what the
Taliban did to the collections in the
National Museum for those final months
that they were in power in 2001
when the staff were able to return in
early 2002 to the National Museum it was
literally sweeping up damaged destroyed
objects and putting them in boxes and
just putting them away so over the years
some of that was rehabilitated but part
of what the University of Chicago under
the State Department has been doing
there is to do archival rehousing of
everything while cataloging this is an
image we saw earlier in one of the
presentations very briefly and it's one
that will be most familiar to all of us
perhaps as a kind of iconic and
devastating glimpse of the power of
cultural destruction what I would like
to talk about and much less well-known
than the destruction of the Buddha's in
Bamiyan was the complete destruction of
a very important yet small provincial
museum in Afghanistan in the city of
ghazni which in its day was a major
kushan or Buddhist settlement part of
the Great Silk Road following that was
the Islamic capital of the ghaznavi
Empire which stretched all the way from
Iran Caspian Sea across to India and
responsible for the spread of Islam in
the 11th century and had been excavated
extensively by the Italians mostly in
the 50s through the 70s and a little bit
in more recent day a museum there with a
very important collection of pre-islamic
and Islamic art which sits in sort of
the center of the capital of ghazni
province which has the same name Ghazni
the city and that museum also happens to
be co-located with the public library
the governor's compound and an internet
cafe which were all the target of an
enormous car explosion the museum itself
was not the single target but it was
destroyed and in that state of
destruction now since to 2014 is how it
looks today
the area is so kinetic as we say or
dangerous with Taliban that even the
Afghan museum staff aren't safe to go to
try to sort of recoup the damage I'm
going to very quickly talk about a new
project that I'm involved in which is
tracking looting of archaeological sites
across Afghanistan estimates are that
well over ninety percent of
archaeological sites have already been
looted and the network of illicit
excavation and the traffic of
Antiquities is a very sophisticated
operation in Afghanistan these are not
sort of simply on the level of poor and
illiterate farmers digging it is it is
structured through a very hiker
hierarchical and powerful with a
powerful base of influential Afghans who
are encouraging this and often what we
do know about it is that not in every
case but often these this traffic
illegal traffic of Antiquities is
financing private militias and other
nefarious activities this is also going
to be a project will it actually just
started a few months ago again through
the university of chicago where they're
taking satellite imagery we also have
this is 2001 the image on the right we
have images also that we're using from
that were captured just in the last
couple of years why this is also useful
new archaeological sites are being
discovered so that's beneficial and the
hope is that this information that's
gathered can then be provided to the
Afghan government who does have a police
force of about 25 to monitor
archaeological sites across the entire
country of Afghanistan so obviously 25
police are not going to be adequate for
that but it's a step
and I think I may be out of time is that
right okay so I'm going to leave you
with this very tantalizing image of a
massive archaeological site just south
of Kabul that happens to be co-located
with the world's second largest copper
deposit and that copper mining will
begin no one knows for sure when and the
reason no one knows for sure is a
staggeringly complex arrangement of a
Chinese copper mining company bad
security a corrupt Afghan government
trying to make it all work in the
meantime archaeologists since 2009 have
been excavating what is one of the
largest kushan era sort of monastic
complexes that was extracting and
processing copper on an industrial level
between the second to the eighth
centuries ad probably before that's a
different story for us archaeologists to
get all geeked out on that but the work
goes on some examples of the objects and
also to what end these materials rather
in a sort of bold statement of taking
entirely Buddhist artifacts for display
in the National Museum in Kabul and
advertising it and inviting school
groups to come to see this with the idea
of let's talk about let's demonstrate a
time and the evidence of when
Afghanistan was a bit more inclusive em
in its historical views and I'll simply
close again with this simple and elegant
plaque outside the National Museum which
I hope all of you will see one day
you